all right guys
bang bang whoa whoa lunch money time
while while she's trying to get rich
right let's just try and get a lunch
money right
let's get it don't forget that i'm now
here with polina she's so beautiful and
way more intelligent than me and she
also has her guns out i don't but she
does
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five
allows you to do
three things buy and sell crypto deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar
loan three or earn up to eight point six
percent apy an interest bearing account
no brainer go check out blockbuy.com
pomp and get yourself an interest
bearing account i'm an investor i'm a
user
and i'm a fan blockbuy.com
what's up someone is being very loud
today i'm being loud
because i woke up like 15 minutes ago
the podcast we launched yesterday is
number one in the world
it's business do you want to tell them
about the podcast we haven't talked
about the podcast
i launched a podcast yesterday with
bryce hall who's one of the most popular
uh social media stars in the world take
talkers uh
he's on youtube as well don't disrespect
my guy and
it's now sitting at number nine in the
world we're trying to get to number one
we're 12 hours in
i think that either by the end of today
or sometime tomorrow we'll be at number
one
you're going to surpass joe rogan yes
wow
what's up joe you want to come on oh god
um
we'll see we got a long list of people
yeah a long list of people guess who
hasn't gotten an invite yet
okay let's get into the news today
just saying let's go the collapse in
aviation caused by the covid pandemic
could wipe out 46 million jobs worldwide
according to new research that
highlights just how damaging a prolonged
downturn in air travel and tourism is
for the global economy
wow 46 million dollars or a million jobs
that's a lot
they think that's how much they're going
to lose worldwide yeah
i mean look so yeah that's a lot job
losses that airlines airports and civil
air space
companies alone could amount to 4.8
million by the beginning of next year
a 40 reduction in employment from levels
before the pandemic
yeah that's pretty crazy that's not
going to be good for the global economy
it is not but at the end of the day you
know what they say
what do they say open the economy back
up get the flights going
let's go let's get let's get this thing
building back up
it'll be all right it will be okay
should we tell the people where we're
going next week
no okay we're going somewhere but we're
not telling you all right what's next
okay um palantir there's two
unicorn companies that are going public
today via direct
listing not your traditional ipo not
your granddaddy's ipo
so the two companies are palantir and
asana
they could reshape the ipo market talent
here is
big data co-founded by peter thiel debut
on the new york stock exchange so will
asana which is run by facebook
co-founder and former chief technology
officer dustin moskowitz
is peter thiel backing both of these no
no
i don't think so he's not an investor in
asana i don't believe something
okay maybe it's just a facebook
connection peter till was the original
investor in facebook did five hundred
thousand dollars dustin moskomis was a
co-founder he did asana
pretty cool to see them kind of come
back just in moscow it's in the social
network movie
uh i believe he was i don't remember
which character he was though
he's he's very very smart oh i think he
was the one in the beginning in the dorm
room that was like super smart
uh yeah so i mean look direct listings
are obviously becoming more popular
spax have gone absolutely nuts we'll see
what happens here but uh i tend to think
that um
we are going to see many many more
companies trying the public markets
they're frothy
uh there's a lot of upside there so
we'll see what happens and direct
listings
were normally used for companies that
have name recognition right so when
slack was going public people were like
and do people really
know slack like and it's like yes it's
very well known
even though it's a what is it called uh
business communication business
communication
company and so same with volunteers sam
with the sauna people know those names
these companies are gonna do well i
think right that's not stock advice i
don't care about stocks but
i do think they're both gonna do well gm
is extending talks on two billion dollar
deal with nicola after fraud sexual
assault allegations surface
against trevor milton who is the founder
so the partnership would give gm an 11
stake in the company for supplying
nikola battery and fuel cell
technologies
as well as producing nicolas badger
pickup this is a good idea to be doing
right now
like i understand you know
you know jump on an opportunity this is
not the opportunity you want to be
jumping on
i actually think what would be really
interesting is that gm made an activist
move here to try to take over nicola
and do it with very little capital so
they basically said look
you like this is a [ __ ] show it's
literally a dumpster fire
uh we're general motors like we
generally have our [ __ ] together
let us step in and we'll take over this
business and we'll try to salvage what
we can
uh and like let's roll the problem is
that there's too many shareholders that
are probably going to be against
something like that
um but i do think you need a consensus
to be an activist
investor well they need to open a lot of
times happens
and this is very over generalization so
anyone listening who knows all the
details don't get upset
but basically what you can do is let's
say you get a certain amount of uh
ownership so if i can buy up
five percent or ten percent of a
business and then i basically go to the
board and i'm like hey
i'm a i'm a shareholder in this business
and i'm gonna keep buying up the shares
uh and basically i'm gonna make a move
on this business
uh and then i'm gonna go around to all
my other shareholders and we're all
gonna
like partner up basically and when we
partner up we're gonna
try to vote you out we're gonna try to
get you fired as ceo like we're going to
like create an absolute mess for you and
a nightmare and a headache
unless you do what we want you to do and
a lot of times what they're trying to do
is they're trying to drive more
shareholder value so they say hey
plano you're running the business uh we
think that you should sell that division
off so you get more cash
you should focus your efforts whatever
they may go to the board and say hey you
guys don't have enough diversity at the
board level like all that kind of stuff
successful activist investors not only
one can get the change two
sometimes they get board seats out of it
they do all kinds of crazy stuff
and then there's this whole strategy of
activist investing which is
i buy up shares in your company and you
take well no
and then i get let's say i get 10 and
then i just act like a complete
maniac and i'm just a you know like a
sore in your
was it a thorn in your side right and
i'm just like
literally you go to sleep thinking about
me you wake up thinking about me you go
to work and all you do is talk about
difference
and when that happens you eventually
come to me go look dude here's the deal
we'll just buy your shares from you and
you'll pay me you know i
bought them at 20 bucks a share and
you'd be like look we'll just pay 29
a share yeah and so i just made you know
40 50 on uh my investment
and all of a sudden now i just go away
i just got paid to go away right so that
type of activism works as well
uh i don't agree with that type of
activism but that's the way that people
will
do it okay uh so
hold on a second so german asset manager
allianz
is that how you say has been accused of
making reckless bets
with the pensions of american teachers
truck drivers subway workers and
firefighters during the coronavirus
market meltdown
the metropolitan transportation
authority the mta
which operates the new york city subway
and the retirement fund for the public
school teachers in arkansas
are among the investors seeking damages
from allianz for losses totaling over
3 billion what were they betting on
what do you mean how are they being
reckless
negligent and imprudent yeah but who's
doing this
allianz asset management yeah but of
their breaches of sustain but this is a
lawsuit right
yeah it's a litigation from investors
at the end of the day what ends up
happening is like people made fortunes
and lost fortunes
in all that market volatility and if
you're on the losing end
you just get mad right nobody wants to
lose money and they're like oh you
are you yawning that's a lot of yawning
going on yawning
roll back the tape she was yelling uh
but what you end up doing is you end up
yelling and screaming and being like
look
uh i want my money back or you know you
were negligent they kind of go
after uh the asset manager and so you
know
i have no clue i don't know all the
details here what i do know is mta is
definitely under a lot of pressure
uh because there's uh revenue is down
from people riding the subway
and so it just gets into this weird
situation where you're like
yikes let's see what happens we rode the
subway for the first time yesterday
it was weird okay next he got an auntie
anne's pretzel
yeah auntie anne's is my [ __ ] shout out
catcall so we talked about this
yesterday but
nearly two-thirds of new york
restaurants may have to close by
january wow two-thirds is way higher
than i previously heard
uh they could be out of business as soon
as january without some sort of
additional government aid
restaurants across new york have been
struggling to stay in business since
covenant began
yeah nearly 64 restaurant owners said
they are likely or somewhat likely to
close by the end of this year unless
they receive
financial relief to be honest i'm
shocked and i do not know how they are
still
surviving yeah this is pretty crazy
conditions
it's pretty crazy but it's also really
really cool how uh
good i think today new york is allowing
25
of people to sit in stores yeah today
september
i thought that we were going to see 20
of small businesses not restaurants but
small businesses across the country go
out of business
by the end of this then we saw uh in new
york i'd asked a friend of mine
um who uh is very into kind of food
um and restaurant hospitality world in
new york
and uh when he estimated to me was 50
now we're talking about 66 oh my gosh
that's the third one just so anyway
he estimated 50 now they're saying 66
like that's a pretty big
increase even 50 was high 66 like jeez
so
we'll see there's a ukrainian restaurant
i used to go with my friend caroline
um and it says the i guess the co
owner caroline um say the restaurant the
restrictions on indoor seating are
killing his business
and he said we would find it very
difficult to survive past january i'm
doing the best i can right now
that just breaks my heart it's a really
great one what happens
all right next okay amazon
okay amazon is looking for ways
to make people's lives easier i should
not have gone to i'm on the press
release so now it's going to be all
press releasey
it's an amazon one is a new innovation
to make
everyday activities effortless basically
they want to take your
palm and use your biometric data to scan
you in stores to scan you out of stores
what what are they going to want they're
going to use the palm signature so that
is
unique to me you guys don't have that
she doesn't have that it's for me and
you can
swipe to touch it no i think you just
swipe your palm
oh yeah contactless way and basically
what happens is you can pay to check out
you can get access to your office your
gym whatever
uh here's the problem you're iris you
don't get a second one it's like if you
if you lose your password or somebody
steals your password to a website
you can reset it you can't reset your
iris your facial scan
you can't reset it your palm you can't
reset it so you better be very careful
i've never
used face id on my phone never i get
that they got security i get that it's
all this
yada yada whatever you never get another
one and so what we're seeing is the
classic paradox between convenience
and privacy and so if you want privacy
you probably shouldn't take things that
are more convenient if you want
convenience don't care about your
privacy
so give them everything give them your
blood an amazon prime store
originally opened near my job so i was
like let's go check it out and he was
like okay
you did not tell me why so then i like
went in and i was like are you not
coming he was like no i'm good i'll just
wait out here i think i have to like a
call or something i was like okay
and then i came out he was not on a call
and i was like you just didn't want to
go in because they would scan your face
and they would
find you whatever i'm not giving them my
face and so yeah he
he refuses to go into himself but i feel
like
okay you can feel like whatever you want
i'm not giving them my face you know
what we're all freaking out about amazon
palm
but you know what when i was a freshman
in college
to get into my dorm we had to slide
our hand on a reader and that's how we
would go in
so i've been palm you know
okay also wait
somebody asked or amazon's faq why did
you pick palm recognition
we selected palm recognition for a few
important reasons one reason was that
palm recognition
is considered more private than some
biometric alternatives
because you can't determine a person's
identity by looking at
image of their palm you can't really
look at somebody's iris and be like that
is paulina's iris
we'll see just be careful that's all i'm
gonna say all right let's go
you got a joke for us no instead of a
joke i ended up on the rent the runway
website
i don't know how that happened okay
um we'll wait okay
wait waiting
waiting waiting remember
go check out blockfy.com pomp go follow
me on twitter
pompletter.com go subscribe i write an
email every day 75
000 people why do ducks have feathers
why to cover up their butt quack
i don't even get it not only it's not
fun i don't even get it you don't get
that
maybe you should look at it
still don't get it i don't even think
that's how you spell quack i don't think
you spell
q-w-a-c-k i think it's pretty sure it's
q-u-a-c-k
but hey what do i know well maybe i
should have just read off some of the
rent thrown away website
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today while she's trying to get
rich let's just try to get our lunch
money right
go subscribe rate and review search
capital university in your podcast app
especially if you're on apple go to
apple podcast find capital university
and rate review and subscribe to put us
to number one the mark cuban episode is
pretty good i'm not gonna lie listen
bang
bang see you guys bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends